yep you gotta lick the Yetta lift it
first one two three okay here's how I
want our parental so you basically want
to live in a sleepaway camp
come on
whoa
what's up here put that at crap why
didn't you get paper plates again I
don't know something about the
environment or something [ __ ] in
front of me it's really bad right now
okay [ __ ] seals [ __ ] polar bears
where's the rest of our kitchen I can't
lift my arms I'm so mean y'all weak
anyhow I'll carry this
okay this
Hey whoa it was a lot later than I
thought or should we move it over there
what you doing over there
no after we do it here
what do you decide decide right so when
they say illegal does that mean
immediately legal I think so does that
mean I could smoke on the board without
anyone bothering me we live in
California you always could have done
this hi I get nervous when you get that
ficus I thought you bought it I never
bought that no I wouldn't buy a ficus
what are you doing oh that's right we
don't live here anymore
sorry man all right why are you here oh
we live like two houses down we just
made a mistake it's fine get out all
right wait yes get out leave oh my god
oh okay
no no oh oh